le champ du possible est extrêmement
vaste moi je dis assez souvent que me
semble-t-il et vous l'avez évoqué ces
technologie en général ont été orienté
dans une logique extrêmement
consumériste euh les gains de
productivité qu'on a eu au cours des 50
dernières années ont été quasiment tous
réinvestis euh dans un accroissement de
du potentiel de de de consommation pas
toujours en bien euh d'ailleurs et là
aujourd'hui on a quand même une
technologie de productivité qui arrive à
un moment où on a un enjeu majeur qui
s'appelle la transition environnementale
donc ce qu'on sait c'est que ça va nous
coûter entre 3 et quat points de PIP par
an jusqu'en 2050 c'est de l'argent que
personne n'a sur terre peut-être à par
les
cataris avec des moyens qui sont pas
forcément les plus écologiques qu' soit
et donc finalement soit on on dit bah on
va faire des efforts de redistribution
majeur ce qui peut poser ça dépend
jusqu'où on va mais dans certains cas ça
frottement peut être relativement
important so on se dit finalement on a
des gains de productivité et ces gains
de productivité plutôt que de les
réinvestir dans le consumérisme on va
les tourner vers cette transition et et
je crois que je n'insisterai jamais
assez sur l'opportunité qu'il y a
d'avoir finalement ces deux phénomènes
de façon simultanée je pense que c'est
vraiment une chance qu'il faut saisir